et il faut chasser les autres
tout l'automne se livrent à leur tour
nivet ou plaisir d'émettre réunis par le
lieutenant de louveterie il se retrouve
toute la saison pour des battues de
destruction sangliers et renard rue de
société d'hommes ils sentent le cuir in
blue mouillé société d'aspect féodal
inébranlable pourtant la menace prend
brutalement entre deux rives
et pourquoi les propriétaires ou recel
[Musique]
[Rires]
en disant qu'on n'a plus besoin d'eux ne
cherche-t-il pas à conjurer le sort
j'avais un piège par là oui j'en ai un
peu loin là encore à peu près 40 m ainsi
on va aller à peut-être quelque chose se
passe une récente une écurie ne pas
plutôt à sa défensive qui m'ont rien
n'est pas tous les jours vingt sur les
derniers trop riche et à d'être trop
l'époux ça se vend bien mais déjà les
gardes n'ont plus droit que les rapaces
dévoreur de et de couvet alors que le
gibier la seule richesse au club de
national les métiers d'art d'orgueil
c'est plus vous dirais franchement c'est
bien mettre les plages
aujourd'hui la place de galles c'est la
place d'un bricoleur non non c'est
permettait de garder un métier de
bricoleur mais vous le dire vous le
cache pas et oui mais oui le garde
élèves le gibier comme de la volaille se
plaint royaux couveuse artificielle
vaccination et tout le bataclan à cause
du nombre de pièces exigées pour les
grandes battues lui fait encore du
naturel du gibier qui vit dans les bois
et tous les matins il à grain
distribuer le grain là où il veut que le
gibier tiennent avec la chasse a changé
en sologne
après on a fait des grandes battues j'ai
entendu parlé la dernière bataille il
devait être cette vie pour faire 1 412
500 pièces donc on sait que ça devait
être un peu différent il faut quand même
qu'ils soient ramassés pour l'été comme
ça le garder par derrière dans molière
et des bois il est large et messieurs
voici la pub le marché n'est rien mais
aussi quand la chasse est venu montauban
beaucoup de champagne ça passe tout seul
à bini ça c'est pas la chose que vous
avez connu que vous étiez petit panneau
carré connu la chasse aimons la lega
chien dray il monsieur tout en faisant
un lièvre un perdreau il est heureux
comme un dieu oui on chasse et au
pourquoi les chasseurs ont ils changé à
part ça c'est l'heure c'est d'un nouveau
régime c'est comme les jeunes
aujourd'hui dans le temps il y avait des
bateaux comme nous aujourd'hui à peu de
bateaux c'est les voleurs de voitures
selebi de maisons secondaires
aujourd'hui ouvriers ou possédant des
bois il ya bien peu de colle et qu'est
ce que vous voulez qu'il ya plus de la
paix c'est lui qui t'a collé gros plan
dans la famille cravate heures à l'appel
pourquoi n'y aurait plus à non il n'a
plus jamais ça va plus ça finisse alors
si on peut on penser aussi au moins fait
je n'ai rien voilà quatre ans de
chasseurs ces messieurs veulent se
transformer en tireur à l'acide
signe des temps comme la disparition
inattendue braquo et de ses collègues
un braconnier un vrai en voici un
pourtant braconné le père pointeau n'a
connu que cela de toute sa vie de son
union c'est le dernier le seul sérieux
qui reste tout le monde le dit et
surtout les vieux garde qui lui ont
couru après pendant 40 ans signent parmi
les signes il est tellement connue
officielle en somme dans son rôle de
braconniers on a pu tout naturellement
installé une caméra près de lui et le
regard des faits depuis combien de temps
vous poser des collets même qu'à tous
ses rôles éponyme du vieux matériel en
or en libye mais économiser jal est
relancé j'en fais c'est à dire se
définissait rganisée je trouve que ça
leur hôtel
je le pose en homme il vient noir comme
ça ça ne retrouve plus les raids se
radoucit plus dangereux surtout qui
aurait ri vival et petit aventure telle
aventure il poursuit c'est quoi à des
américaines des poursuites au chalet
courir à la accueillis chaque année pour
le demander puis elle est tombée malade
et jusqu'à 4,5 lancé l'échappée
oui mais le gars n'étaient là à quelques
mètres s'en approcher mais ce qui
m'étonne monsieur pointeau c'est que
tout le monde sait que vous êtes
braconniers ah oui et lorient on vous
laisse faire
jégo pour parler local avec tout le
monde le sait dans la wii à batoumi
c'est sûr on vous laisse tranquille
quand même y en a qui me disait rien il
est ouvert aujourd'hui vous dire que
j'ai vu c'est pour lui j'y vois pas ces
propos devant s'attaquer serbe
je veux dire que maintenant vous me
reconnais plus ah non écoute braconniers
ne reconnaît plus ce matin vous aviez un
petit lapin pour la wii mais ça et rien
que ça c'est rien
qu'est ce que c'est braconné alors avoir
braconné vous font rire et continue à
l'immobilier régime aux yeux c'est pas
pareil pendant ce temps bras sa main le
garde s'était rapproché à tirer malgré
lui par notre conversation
oui après la guerre longtemps que la
guerre n'était pas en janvier
et ça fait 25 ans qui était en réalité
c'était un petit auditoire le bon du
côté de tout côté de la route n'ont pas
dit non mon client mais monsieur brasse
amant est-ce que c'est du vol le
braconnage c'est affaire de goût vous
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
trouvez que c'est du vol pourquoi je
suis pas considéré comme vole quand même
ça n'allait pas mais on en est pas moins
condamné c'est à dire j'ai fini le beau
temps là à monsieur du pointeau c'est
fini le bouton la présence et j'ai la
légère cimetière capello peut pas tout
de suite quand ces gens que certains
d'entre eux se nomme muscade solide
[Musique]